>> HARD CORE HAND WRINGING EVEN
FOR THE LIBERAL MEDIA.
REPUBLICANS GAINING MOMENTUM
WITH ONE WEEK BEFORE THE
MID-TERM ELECTION.
ACCORDING TO SOME, THAT IS
WILDLY DANGEROUS.
>> ELECTION DAY IS JUST DAYS
AWAY.
AT STAKE, POSSIBLY THE FUTURE OF
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> DEMOCRACY DOESN'T USUALLY DIE
THROUGH COUPS OR INVASION BUT
FROM WITHIN.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
GRIPPED BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELECTION DENIERS.
>> I DON'T THINK WE'RE ALARMIST
ENOUGH.
I THINK WE NEED TO STOP BEING
ASLEEP AT THE SWITCH AND SOUND
THE ALARM.
MORE ABOUT WHAT COULD HAPPEN IF
ELECTION DENIALISTS ARE, YOU
KNOW, IN POWER.
>> CRITICS CALLING THIS OUT AS
FEAR MONGERING AND LIBERAL
CHEERLEADING.
JOE CONCHA FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AND COLUMNIST FOR THE HILL IS
HERE.
WOW.
>> THAT'S THE WORD I WOULD USE.
LET ME SEE IF I GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
THIS ISN'T A CLIP FROM THE VIEW
OR MSNBC, THIS IS CBS NEWS.
FOR THEM TO PUSH THIS SORT OF
RHETORIC WHEN THEY SAY THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS FULL OF
ELECTION DENIERS HAVE THEY MET
HILLARY CLINTON AND STACEY
ABRAMS?
THEY REJECTED THE RESULTS OF
THEIR ELECTIONS.
IF WE GET THIS STRAIGHT NOW,
DEMOCRATS APPEAR TO BE SAYING IF
PEOPLE VOTE AGAINST THEIR PARTY
IN DISTRICTS AND STATES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ONE WEEK FROM NOW
AND THE RESULT MEANS A CHANGE IN
POWER IN WASHINGTON FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY THAT'S THE END OF
DEMOCRACY AS WE KNOW IT?
ACTUALLY VOTING IS THE VERY
ESSENCE OF DEMOCRACY.
I HAVE A HARD TIME BELIEVING
THAT THIS IS REALLY RESONATING
WITH INDEPENDENT VOTERS OR BLUE
DOG DEMOCRATS WHO MAY BE ON THE
FENCE AS FAR AS HOW THEY WILL
VOTE IN A WEEK.
IF ANYBODY THINKS PEOPLE WILL
SAY I'M STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR
FOOD, RENT AND ELECTRIC BILLS
AND I DON'T FEEL AS SAFE AS I
USED TO A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
SCREW THAT, I WILL VOTE TO SAVE
DEMOCRACY INSTEAD.
IT IS SOME OF THE BEST
UNINTENTIONAL COMEDY OUT THERE.
IF THAT'S THE CLOSING ARGUMENT
FROM THE BLUE TEAM AND ALLIES IN
THE MEDIA THEY'RE IN SERIOUS
TROUBLE ON NOVEMBER 8TH.
>> I WROTE DOWN IN MY THOUGHTS.
DEMOCRACY AT WORK WHEN PEOPLE
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE AND
VOTE BASED ON THE ISSUES THAT
MATTER TO THEM, INFLATION AND
THE ECONOMY, DEMOCRACY AT WORK
IS A RISK TO DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHAT JERRY BAKER GETS TO
IN HIS COLUMN.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
DENIAL, IT IS DENIAL BY THE
DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE BEEN IN
POWER, THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH, FOR OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF.
THEIR DENIAL THAT NOT EDGE THEY
CREATED THESE PROBLEMS BUT THERE
IS A PROBLEM AT ALL.
>> IT'S LIKE BEING AN ALCOHOLIC
AND NOT ADMITTING THE FIRST STEP
THAT YOU HAVE A PROBLEM.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY YOU TACKLE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
YOU LOOK AT GEORGIA, AND YOU SEE
THEY ARE AGAIN VOTING IN RECORD
NUMBERS AND YET THE DEMOCRAT
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR DOWN THERE
INSISTS THAT VOTER SUPPRESSION
IS STILL HAPPENING DESPITE
PEOPLE GETTING TO THE POLLS AND
GETTING THERE EASILY WITHOUT
ANYBODY BEING SUPPRESSED.
IT IS GETTING BORING AT THIS
POINT WHEN THEY KEEP SCREAMING
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN ON
OTHER NETWORKS AND REALLY DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO BACK IT UP.
NOW DO THEY?
HERE IS WHERE WE ARE AND WHY YOU
SEE THE MOMENTUM BEHIND
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THINGS
THAT MATTER TO PEOPLE.
THE BORDER, IMMIGRATION,
EDUCATION AND NOT JUST INFLATION
AND CRIME.
>> I HEARD SOMEBODY SAY
INFLATION DESTROYS SOCIETY AND
THAT REALLY STUCK WITH ME.
SPEAKING OF DESTRUCTION, CRITICS
LIGHTING UP THE VIEW HOSTS OVER
THE HALLOWEEN DAY SHOW ACCUSING
THE SHOW OF USING CHILDREN IN
COSTUMES TO MOCK REPUBLICANS
WITH THE MID-TERMS ONE WEEK
AWAY.
THE HOSTS, BOY, THEY WERE EATING
IT UP.
>> ONE OF THE HUGEST TOPICS YOU
GUYS TALKED ABOUT THIS YEAR, THE
RAID ON TRUMP'S MAR-A-LAGO
ESTATE.
>> YES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WHAT DID HE DO?
HE FLUSHED THEM DOWN THE TOILET.
WE HAVE TRUMP AS A TOILET WITH
OUR F.B.I. AGENTS.
HERE WE HAVE OUR DR. OZ.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WE HAVE THE BROCCOLI AND
SAUCE AND --
>> CRITICS LASHING OUT CALLING
THE SPECTACLE INSANE AND
DERANGED.
JOE, WHAT SAY YOU?
>> THIS IS TRUMP DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME TIMES TEN.
IT IS SICK.
I HAVE A FIRST AND THIRD GRADER
WITH THE HALLOWEEN PARADE AND NO
ONE WAS DRESSED UP AS F.B.I.
AGENTS.
USING KIDS AS PROPS TO MAKE A
POLITICAL STATEMENT AND THINKING
IT IS FUNNY.
ABC CONTINUES TO TAKE THIS TRAIN
WRECK OF A SHOW UNDER ITS NEWS
DIVISION.
MCCAIN LEFT AND NOTHING GOOD TO
SAY.
IT IS A HATE FEST.
NOW IT'S A BORING ONE THAT I
WOULD THINK IT'S BECOME THE ONE
THING THAT BARBARA WALTERS
DIDN'T WANT THE SHOW TO BECOME.
IT IS BECOME PREDICTIBLE AND
CO-HOSTED BY SOME OF THE MOST
UNLIKEABLE PEOPLE ON THE PLANET.
ANOTHER BLACK EYE FOR "THE
VIEW."
>> I THOUGHT IF KIDS DRESSED UP
AS LAW ENFORCEMENT THEIR HEADS
WOULD HAVE EXPLODED AND THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
CHILD ABUSE.
WHAT IS SOMEONE THIS YEAR
DRESSED UP AS JOHN FETTERMAN,
OZ'S OPPONENT.
I BUTTON